[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرسم معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
ناشطون ايرانيون ودول غربيه يشككون في
حقيقه تاثير قرار ايران الغاء شرطه
الاخلاق
شركه طبيه تابعه لالماسك تواجه تحقيقا
اتحاديا بمزاعم انتهاكات لحقوق الحيوان
وفي كاس العالم المغرب يواجه اسبانيا
اليوم في دوري 16 والبرتغال في مواجهه مع
سويسرا
اهلا بكم قل لا لا ننشطون ايرانيون ودول
غربيه من اهميه اعلان السلطات الايرانيه
الغاء جهاز شرطه الاخلاق مشددين على ان اي
تغيير لم يقرا على القيود المشدده التي
يفرضها النظام الايراني على النساء فيما
اكدت الخارجيه الامريكيه انها لم ترى ما
يدل على ان النظام الايراني تحسن في طريقه
معاملته للنساء والفتيات او حتى توقف
العنف الذي يتعامل به مع المتظاهرين
السلميين بدور هذا كره الخارجيه الالمانيه
ان المتظاهرين الايرانيين يريدون العيش
بحريه واستقلاليه وان الغاء شرطه الاخلاق
في حال تطبيقه لن يغيرها من الامر اطلاقا
من جهه اخرى انتشرت على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي دعوات لتنفيذ اضراب مدته ثلاثه
ايام يبلغ ذروته الاربعاء تزامنا مع يوم
الطالب بعد نحو ثلاثه اشهر على اندلاع
موجه اضطرابات التي اثارها مقتل مهس اميني
بعد توقيفها من جانب شرطه الاخلاق هذا
وكانت النائب الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب
الامريكي اليز ستيفانك قد عبرت عبر صفحتها
الرسميه على موقع تويتر وقوفها الى جانب
الشعب الايراني الذي وصفته بالشجاع وقالت
انه يعاني في ظل نظام الاستبداديين قاتل
وفقه تعبيرها
ورغم قرار النظام الايراني الغاء شرطه
الاخلاق لا تزال التظاهرات مشاهدينا
مستمره في مدن ايرانيه عديده لا سيما
العاصمه طهران ومحافظه خرزان وفارس وحتى
مشهد شمالا شرقي ايران المتظاهرون رفعوا
شعارات تردد بمسارات بممارسات النظام
الايراني على الرغم من اعلان انتهاء مهمه
ما يطلق عليها بشرطه الاخلاق
[تصفيق]
الله
ينضم الينا من سيدني الباحث في الشان
الايراني احمد الياسري سيد احمد اهلا بك
معنا في هذه النشره يعني تقليل دولي
وتمديد ودعم للمظاهرات داخل ايران كيف
يمكن ان نفهم هذا التقليل الدولي من خطوه
الغاء شرطه الاخلاق في ايران
الدول الغربيه
النظام لانها شرطه الاخلاق اساسا لم تؤثر
يعني
بالقضاء الايراني
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله همم
شرطه الاخلاق يقال بانها تنتمي لوزاره
الداخليه وان المرشد الاعلى هو الوحيد
الذي لديه صلاحيه لالغاء هذه المؤسسه
الامنيه بالتالي هل المرشدي يعي خطوره
الوضع في ايران هل يعي مطالب المحتاجين ام
كيف نفهم خطوته في الغاء هذه المؤسسه
الامنيه
حزب وحده شعب ايران الاصلاح المقرر يعني
شرطه الاخلاق يا صلاح يستخدمونه المحافظون
ويستخدموهن على حد سواء المحافظون يريدون
ارتباط انهم ملتزمون بطوابط همم
هذه المؤسسه الشرطيه حتى يعني يختارون من
اليسار
الاسلام
[موسيقى]
على همم
القيادات المحافظه
او اللبس المحتشم او غيره من هذه الامور
وانما على الوضع الاقتصادي المتدني في
الداخل الايراني الوضع الاجتماعي الوضع
المعيشي لا نرى اي تغيرات في هذا الصدق
كيف يمكن للاحتجاجات ان تهدا
الجزيره فقط
لا انا اتحدث عن النقطه اللي حضرتك تكسير
ولكن اذا قرانا المشهد
تمر بمنعطف خطير جدا
عام 1979
نفسه
يتحدث عن الضغط الذي تشكله الاحتجاجات
خطبه المرشد وهو مع المسيح كان يتحدث ان
تخوف المرشد من الانضمام مع بعض العمال
والفلاحين الى هذه
الاحتجاجات هي كسرت
النظام يعتمد في امتصاص نقمه الشعب على
خلق ثنائيات الاصلاح المحافظ والمحاكمه
هذه كل القوميات اشتركت بها كل المواقع
الجغرافيه جغرافيه ايران كلها مشتركه
ودافعها ثقافي يتعلق بحريه المراه بما
تمثل المرض طبعا من سر
ايرانيه
هي التي
داخل
القلب
هو حاله الانقسام
شرطه الاخلاق ما الخيارات امام النظام
النظام اعترف عمر قاعدته انه في منعطف
كثير
لانه القضيه تنافس بين المحافظين
لقياده الحرس الثور بمحاوله الاحترام
بالقوه
الشعب الايراني
المتحركه باداره والمحافظات خطيره جدا
كذلك بدات بتحصل القسمات في داخل المنظومه
شكرا جزيلا لك من سيدني الباحث في شان
الايرانيه احمد الياسري
اوكرانيا يؤدي تزويد كييف بالاسلحه
والمعدات العسكريه الاستنفاد الدول
الحلفاء مخزوناتها الخاصه من الاسلحه وذلك
طبعا وفق موقع ديفانس نيوز الامريكي ويسعى
الجيش الامريكي الى زياده كبيره في
الانتاج الشهري لقذائف المدفعيه من عيار
155 مللي متر خلال سنوات الثلاث المقبله
الموقع اضاف ان الولايات المتحده ستنتقل
من صنع 14,000 قذيفه عيار 155 ملم كل شهر
الى 20,000 بحلول الربيع و40,000 بحلول
عام 20 25
يرى ان الحرب في اوكرانيا مستمره الى اجل
غير مسمى مما يزيد من استنزاف مخزونات
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها ومن غير الواضح
ما هي احتياجات الجيش الاوكراني على المدى
المتوسط والطويل وان الجيش الامريكي
مشاهدينا يريد ان يكون جاهزا لمثل هذه
الحالات
والى التطورات الميدانيه اكد حاكم مدينه
كورسكا الروسيه اندلاع عن حريق في خزان
نفط بعد هجوم بمسيرات اوكرانيه واعلنا
حاكم المنطقه رومنستروفي عدما وقوع اي
اصابات لجراء هذا الهجوم مضيفا ان خدمات
الطوارئ تعمل في الموقع وكانت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت اعتراض دفاعاتها
الجويه لعدد من الطائرات المسيره اطلقتها
القوه الاوكرانيه ضد مطرين في مقاطعه
ريزان وسرتوب الروتين
بودره
في صباح اليوم الخامس من ديسمبر الجاري
بهدف تعطيل الطائرات الروسيه بعيده المدى
بمحاولات هجوم بمسيرات على المطارات
العسكريه
الطائره بدون طيار الاوكرانيه التي كانت
تحلق على ارتفاع المنخفض تم اعتراضها من
قبل الدفاع الجوي الروسي
معظمه الصواريخ التي اطلقها الجيش الروسي
يوم امس الامر الذي سمح لمهندسين الطاقه
الكهربائيه الى المناطق التي تضررت بفعل
الضربات الروسيه
مساج راويه
الدفاع عن الجوي وعمال الطاقه لدينا
وشعبنا لقد اسقط الدفاع الجوي معظم
الصواريخ الروسيه وبدع عمال الطاقه في
السعاده امدادات الطاقه شعبنا لا يستسلم
ابدا
اهلا بك رائد ما اخر التطورات لديك على
الميدان
في مقابل
الذي
صباح الباكر والقاسم مستمر في بيت المناطق
الشماليه اكثر من 30 قبيحه وصار من عيارات
مختلفه وافتراسات مختلفه
755 كما اسلفتي فاطمه لابد ان
المستودعات همم مستودعات الدخيره للجيش
الاوكراني تعاني من نقص في همم قذائف من
عيار 155 لان الفتره الم او منذ انطلاق
العمليه العسكريه كانت هي الاكثر استخداما
في الاسبوع الماضي لاحظنا تغير همم في همم
يعني في انواع الاسلحه المستخدمه حيث بات
الجيش الاوكرانيه يستخدم همم راجمات
صواريخ جراند اكثر من تلك القذائف
الامريكيه هذه
الجيش الاوكراني عن مسيرات هل من معلومات
حول ذلك
نحو المناطق التي يتمركز فيها الجيش
الروسي وكذلك الاحياء المدنيه وهنا قصف
بالمسيرات حسب السلطات المحليه هنا لكن
على اهم ان كل هذه العمليات العسكريه تتم
بشكل مع عمليات اقتحام لجيش الروسي في
شمال المقاطعه الثانيه مدينه ضخمه تشهد
منذ الامس واليوم عمليه اقتحام من القوات
الروسيه من
الناحيه الشرقيه الجنوبيه تحاول انطلاق
القوات الروسيه من مدينه اوربطناها في تلك
المنطقه وتحاول دخول المدينه كما ان
المدينه المدينه
تعاني في هذه الايام من ضغط روسي كبير
تحاول القوات
نعم ايضا الدخول الى
مدينه ماركا القريبه جدا من غرب المدينه
وهنا حرب الشوارع ما بين الجيش الاوكراني
والجيش الروسي تقول الدفاع الروسيه بان
الجيش الاوكراني ماذا لا يقاتل مدافع عن
المدينه وكذلك سلطات المحليه هنا القصف
يعني يستهدف فقط مقاطعه دانيه
بالامس ايضا شهدت قصف بصواريخ سته صواريخ
مبنى سكنيه حتى الان 14 قتيلا واكثر من 25
مصاب في هذه البنايه وحدها ما زالت عمليه
الاستهداف الاوكرانيه للبنا تحتيه
والمساكن والمدن مستمره وبالفعل تقول
السلطات هنا بان همم يعني هذه العمليه هي
انتقاميه بسبب التقدم الروسي في هذا
المحور ايضا نصحت السلطات المواطنين عدم
الخروج الى الشوارع
وكذلك اصدرت بيانا بايقاف العمل في
المؤسسات الحكوميه او العمل من المنازل
همم تشهد المنطقه الشرقيه تطورا كبيرا في
هذه الايام فاطمه فهو الاكثر سخونه من دون
انطلاق العمليه العسكريه
رائد الاخبار
اكدا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
لانشائي محكمه دوليه بشان جرائم الحرب في
اوكرانيا وقال ابنكن اليسا
من المهم السماح بجمع المعلومات الضروريه
لتحديد المتورطين في ارتكاب جرائم حرب
وتمكين اوكرانيا اللازمه الامر من
محاسبتهم وكانت البعثه الروسيه في الامم
المتحده اكدت ان جاءها اليه اماميه
للتحقيق في جرائم حرب يتطلب موافقه مجلس
الامن والتي بدونها تكون المحكمه
الاوروبيه المقترحه بشان اوكرانيا مستحيله
يعقد مجلس الامن مشاهدينا جلسه مفتوحه
لمناقشه تاثير الحرب في اوكرانيا على
الاطفال وذلك بطلب من فرنسا والمكسيك تاتي
هذه الجلسه بعد تصاعد الهجمات الصاروخيه
الروسيه والقذف الجوي ضد البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه وخاصه محطات توليد الطاقه
الكهربائيه وسط انباء عن امكانيه ان تتطرق
السفيره الامريكيه عن استعداد الرئيس
للقاء بوتين اذا كان لديه اهتمام حقيقي
لانهاء الحرب وسحب قوته من اوكرانيا من
عمان ينضم الينا اللواء الركن محمد محمود
الثلجي المحلل العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
بك معنا في هذه النشره همم سعاده اللواء
همم اوكرانيا تستخدام المسيارات لقصف
الداخل الروسي
وتستهدف يعني مطار او مطرين الى الان في
الداخل الروسي كيف يمكن لذلك ان يغير من
اللعبه على الارض
مرحبا بك يا سيدتي وبالاخوه المشاهدين هذا
هذا يقودنا سيدتي الى
ان نقول بان فصل الشتاء بدا يفرض ايقاعه
بقوه على طبيعه الصراع في ما بين الطرفين
الطرف الروسي والطرف الاوكراني وتجنب
المواجهه المباشره في كثير من مناطق مناطق
الصراع ومناطق القتال وهذا مشاهدته خير
شون وبالتالي لجا الطرفين الى وسائل قتال
بعيده المدى كما لجعل الجانب الصوره
الروسي الى استخدام صواريخ وبكثافه الان
يعني دفع هذا الاستخدام الجانب الاوكراني
الى التفكير في وسائل ربما يعني هي ليست
جديده ولكن هي جديده بطبيعتها وجديده بطول
مداها وهي طائرات المشيره وهذا ربما يعني
يعطي انذارا بانه باكرانيا باتت تمتلك الى
طائرات مشيره ربما قادر على الوصول
الاستراتي الطائرات
اتوقع سيدتي بانه اذا لم يتم تط اذا ما تم
تطويرها يعني محليا فانه تم تجويدها بها
من قبل الاطراف الداعمه اما من قبل
الاوروبيين ومن قبل الامريكيين ولكن يعني
استهداف داخل الروسي كان خط احمر بالنسبه
لبوتل وكذلك بالنسبه لبايدن يعني كان في
البدايه يرفض ان يزود اوكرانيا باي اسلحه
بعيده المدني الا تستهدف الاراضي الروسيه
وتجنب التصعيد نعم سيدتي
العلميه في سبعين صاروخ ردا على هجمات
يعني حقيقه هذه الهجمات الاوكرانيه هي
كانت تحمل رمزيه اكثر من ما كانت يعني
ايقاع ضرر بالجانب الروسي هي لم توقع ذلك
الضرر البالغ الذي يؤثر على سير العمليات
ويؤثر على فعاليات الجانب الروسي في اداؤه
القتال ولكن كان لها رمزيه كبيره جدا من
اكثر من ناحيه الناحيه الاولى اولا ان هذه
الطائرات المسيره تخطت مسافه تتجاوز 800
كيلو متر وبالتالي هي وصلت الى الحد الذي
نقول بانه بانها عمليه وصلت الى العمق
الاستراتيجي للقوات الرويال للقوات
الروسيه او لروسيا هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه
اخرى وسيدتي كيف لهذه الطائرات ان تسير كل
هذه المسافه بدون ان تكتشفها وسائل
الانذار ووسائل الدفاع الجوي وتصل الى هذه
القواعد الجويه وهذا ينذر بان هنالك خللا
وخطا كبيرا في حمايه القواعد الجويه
الروسيه في الداخل الروسي يعني ربما ايضا
يعطي حافزا اكبر للاكرانيين باستهداف
المزيد ويعني همم لا ادري القوات الروسيه
في حاله حرب والقواعد الجويه ليست محميه
بالقدر الكافي الذي يمكنها من حمايه نفسه
وبالتالي وصلت هذه الطائرات هذا ينكر كثير
سعاده اللواء يعني تطرح حول هذا شان وهناك
تساؤلات ايضا تطرح حول قدره اوكرانيا على
الفعل بتصنيع طائرات مسيره بهذا الحجم
يعني شركه الصناعات او الصناعات الاسلحه
التابعه للحكومه الاوكرانيه كانت تشير
لعده اسابيع ماضيه عن تطويرها لطائرات
مسيره جديده بعيده المدى ولكن بالفعل
اوكرانيا قادره على ان تطور مثل هذه
الاسلحه ام ان هذا غطاء لبعض الدول التي
بالفعل تزود ربما اوكرانيا بهذه الاسلحه
سيدتي اذا اذا نظرنا الى التاريخ
الاوكراني واوكرانيا من 1991 ورثت عن
الجانب السوفيتي الكثير من من المصانع
والكثير من من القواعد الجويه والقواعد
العسكريه هي لديها قاعده صناعيه قويه جدا
وهي قادره على تطوير اسلحه فيما اذا تم
تجويدها بتقنيه حديثه جدا ويعني لديها
جانب ثقه كبيره ولديها العديد من الخضراء
الذين يستطيعون تطوير يعني هذه الطائرات
المشيره وهي ليست يعني بتلك بتلك الصعوبه
اضافه سيدتي امام يعني هنالك العديد من
الاسلحه التي ظهرت في ساعات القتال
الاوكرانيه لم يتم الاعلان عنها
وهذا يفسر ايضا بان هذه الاسئله وصلت بدون
ان يتم الاعلان عنها وصلت بطريقه سريه همم
ليس ليس مستغربا ان تمتلك اوكرانيا مثل
هذه الطائرات او مثل هذه المسايرات او
صواريخ اخرى
تحدث عن ردود العسكريه هنا نعم سيده
الردود الروسيه الان الان اتخذ الصراع
شكلا اخر نحن اا يعني اوكرانيا الان هاجمت
بالطائرات المسيره ووصلت الى العمق الروسي
وانا اعتبر هذا النجاح للقوات الاوكرانيه
في هذا الوصول وتخطي جميع الحواجز
الدفاعات الجويه التي كانت تعتز بها روسيا
وتفتخر بان لديه نظم الدفاع الجوي قويه
هذه الطائرات المسيره اخترقتها وصلت الان
رد الروسي تمثل فورا في ارسال في ارسال 70
صاروخ من انواع مختلفه قصفت فيها المدن
الاوكرانيه واستهدفت بها البنيه التحتيه
الان سيدتي المعركه هي معركه البناء
التحتيه معركه المسيرات ضد ضد القدرات
الصاروخيه الروسيه ولكن يعني لا اتوقع بان
المسيرات الاوكرانيه ستحدث ذلك الفرق الذي
تحدده الصواريخ في في ال ال الدمار البنيه
التحتيه الذي يجري في الجانب الاوكراني
واثقاذ اوكرانيا
لطاقتها الكهربائيه وايضا شل شغل الحياه
وادامه الحياه اف هذه المدن الساك بها
وبالتالي جاء على غير قابل للحياه هذا هدف
كبير 9 روسيا الى تحقيق والامر الاخر
سيدتي هنالك امر مهم جدا همم من خلال هذه
المعركه الصاروخيه التي تشن روسيا روسيا
تعلم بان ليست كل صواريخها ستصل الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه او الى اهدافها ولكن
هنالك استنزاف كبير لقدرات ال- ال- انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيا ووضعها تحت ضغط
مستمر في هذا بطبيعه الحال سيشكل الضغط
المستخدم
هل يمكن ان يؤدي الى استخدام النووي الذي
يحذر منه او تحضر منه جميع الدول
لا زالت سيدتي يعني لا يوجد هنالك نذر
توحي
باقتراب الوصول الى استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه روسيا لم تصل الى الحد الذي
يدفعها
الى استخدام هذه الاسلحه لم يتم تهديدها
يعني وجودها كدوله ولم يتم ترديد وجود
قوات الارضيه ولا قواتها الاخرى بالفناء
وبالتالي يعني لا يوجد ذلك اي وسيله او
مبرر لاستخدام هذا السلاح حاليا ويعني هذا
سيثير عاصفه من الغضب العالمي والغضب
الدولي باتجاه الروسيه وبالتالي النتائج
ربما ستكون غير محسوبه وغير محسومه شكرا
لك من عمان اللواء الركن محمد محمود
الثلجي المحلل العسكري والاستراتي
اجتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
مطار بكين يعلن الغاء الزاميه تقديم
اختبار سلبي لفيروس كوفد
احييكم من جديد اعلن مطار بكين الدولي
الغاء الزاميه تقديم اختبار سلبي لفيروس
كوفد الدخول الى المباني
ومن ضمنها انها اختبار الكشف الالزمي
للاشخاص الذين يرغبون في استخدام وسائل
النقل العام او حتى الدخول الى الاماكن
العامه الاخرى الى ذلك ذكرت لجنه الصحه
الوطنيه
28,000 اصابه جديده بفيروس
20 ساعه الماضيه منها قرابه خمسه الاف
ظهرت عليها اعراضها واعلن اتحاد نقابات
العمال في كوريا الجنوبيه عن الدخول في
اضراب عام لسائقي صهاريج الوقود وتجمع
سائقه الشاحنات امام نحو مئه محطه وقود في
انحاء كوريا مطالبين مشاهدينا الحكومه
بتمديد نظام اسعار الشحن الذي يضمن لهم
الحد الادنى من الاجور
سيتخذ الرئيس الامريكي القراره بشان ان
كان يترشح لولايه ثانيه في العام 2024 بعد
فتره قصيره من بدء العام الجديد وفق ما
ذكر كبير موظف فيه رون كلاين وقال كلاين
في تصريحات ادلى بها خلال قمه مجلس
الرؤساء التنفيذيين لوصف الجورنا
البالغ من العمر 80 عاما لا يزال يتشاور
مع افراد عائلته بشان قراره ويعد بعيد
الرئيس الاكبر سنا في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده واذا تولى السلطه لولايه ثانيه
فسيكون في السادسه والثمانين من عمره
بحلول الانتهاء ولايته وكلاين قال انه
يترشح بالفعل
تواجه شركه انور لينك للاجهزه الطبيه
والتابعه للملياردير الامريكيه الى الماس
تحقيقا اتحاديا في مزاعم بنتهاكات محتمله
لحقوق الحيوان وذلك واسطه شكاوى من موظفي
في الشركه من تسريع التجارب على الحيوانات
مما تسبب في نفوق الكثير منها من دوني
وثائق طلعت عليها رويترز ومصادر مطلعه على
التحقيق وعمليات الشركه وتعكف انور لينك
عن تطوير شريحه تزرع في الدماغ تامل ان
تساعد المصابين بالشلل على المشي مره اخرى
فضلا عن علاج الامراض عصبيه اخرى من خلال
هذه الشريحه معنا من بيروت استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه الدكتور سامي نادر اهلا بك معنا
دكتور بدايه هل يمكننا
بالفعل هذه القضيه ان تنجح خصوصا وان في
الولايات المتحده هناك همم لا تشريعات
محدده عن عدد الحيوانات المستخدمه في
البحوث والاختبارات
يعني هذه مساله
عفوا
هل تسمعني دكتور
نص عن عدد معين للحيوانات اثناء الاجراء
الاختبارات او البحوث عليها بالتالي ما
اسس هذه القضيه
باخلاقيات
التي ترتكز عليها البحوث العلميه وبالتالي
التشريعات همم
الامريكيه ربما لا تشكل الاطار الكافي
لانه من ناحيه هذه التجارب المستمره والتي
تاخذ ابعدا اكبر اليوم بدفع من
التكنولوجيا هي تتقدم على الاطار التشريعي
يعني مساله التكنولوجيا تسير بسرعه اكبر
بكثير عفوا
التكنولوجيا التفسير بيسرعه اكبر بكثير من
ال- اا
ال- ال- الاطار التشريعي لذلك هنالك هذه
الفجوات التي يعني تقرح همم مشكله كبيره
امام المشرع يعني نراها كل فتره وذلك بسبب
يعني التقدم التكنولوجيا السريع ولكن ستار
لينك او شركه الماسك هذه تحديدا اا يعني
تخطت كل الاختبارات والامتحانات والزيارات
من الوزاره المعنيه للشركه ونجحت فيها
صحيح صحيح
بعد استحواذ ايلون ماسك على تويتر
والجدل الذي اثاره انحياسه همم الى جانب
الحزب الجمهوري بينما الاداره هي الاداره
ديمقراطيه اليوم اصبح واضحا جدا يعني حتى
الماسك لم يخفي هذه النوايا حينما يعني
دعى الامريكيين الى انتخاب همم رئيس
الجمهوري صحيح حلقه من الرئيس ترامب همم
التنحي او الاستراحه همم ولكن كان واضحا
عن في خياراته السياسيه كان على المستوى
السياسي السياسيه
التعبير وهو بذلك شخص
وكل ذلك هل تسمعني دكتور
لن تسهل بناء الامكانيات لدى هذا الرجل
المتمول الناجح والذي قد يغير في المشهد
السياسي لاكان استرلينج او كان التويتر
يعني هي حقيقه همم تشكل همم البنا
لوسائل الاعلام الحديثه التي قد تقلب كافه
الموازين ليس فقط في الداخل الامريكي
لتكون واضحين انما ايضا على المستوى
العالم
الاداره الامريكيه الديمقراطيه
للواضحه
وتتعارض مع مصالحها
امم هذه الوضع السياسي
التوقيت لهذه القضيه هل يمكن ان يكون ضربه
مرتده ربما من المسؤولين السياسيين ضد
ماسك بعد ان همم يعني اخرج او نشر فضائح
وهل يمكن ان تستخدم هذه القضيه ماء صحه
هذه
الادعاءات
بالمقايضه مع ماسك ربما
ولا ل- همم اللي تقاذف الملفات او تبادل
التهم ولذلك تحضر الملفات تماما كما يعني
حاول همم باسك ان يستعمل الملفات المتعلقه
بابن همم الرئيس همم تاثير على الانتخابات
المقبله همم تحت عنوان حريه الاعلام
وبالتالي المعسكر الاخر الديمقراطي همم
يهيء ملفات اخرى كان هذا الذي يتفضل فيه
للهجوم على مصر هو هذا شيء همم
تعودنا عليه في المشهد السياسي الامريكي
الصراع من خلال الملفات كان ملفات اا
متعلقه بالفساد او ملفات متعلقه بخرق
القوانين عامه كما تفضلت
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور سامي نادر
على هذه المداخله
عشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
المغربي يواجهه اسبانيا اليوم في دوري 16
والبرتغال في مواجهه سويسرا
مباشره الى اخبار الاقتصاد مع الزميل ناصر
اليك
شكرا فاطمه اهلا بكم مشاهدينا تحديث
لارقام جلسه تداول هذا اليوم تعميق
الخسائر في السوق الكويتيه بشكل واضح كانت
تراجعات في الكويت
تحوم حول ثلاثه اعشار النقطه المئويه عند
افتتاح الجلسه صباح هذا اليوم لكن خسائر
تعمقت الان الى حوالي 1 ونصف النقطه
المئويه على مؤشر الكويت الاول خسائر ايضا
مماثله من حيث النسبه في سوق الدوحه ولكن
حاله من الاستقرار في السوق السعوديه وفي
دبي وايضا في ابو ظبي الاشاره بانه دبي
مائله للاستقرار لكنها باللون الاخضر منذ
انطلاقه تداولات صباح هذا اليوم في السوق
السعوديه هذه عدد من الاسهم التي نتبعها
دي بتعلن عن استراتيجيه للسنوات الخمس
المقبله جديده المتحده وعنايه همم يقعان
مذكره تفاهم لدراسه جدوى اندماج الشركتين
وتحسين همم الوضع همم المالي والربحيه
للشركاتتين في ظل طبعا ما نشهده من توحيد
وكانديشن في مع التاميني في السوق
السعوديه همم في سوق دبي اتحاد العقاريات
تطلق او تعتزم عن اطلاق مشروع في دبي
عقاري بطريقه الحال بقيمه مليار و600
مليون درهم في ابو ظبي نلحظ مكاسب قويه
جدا على سهم طاقه احجام التداول طبيعيه لا
يوجد اخبار على السهم ننتظر اي افصاح
لشركه طاقه بعد جرس الاغلاق او قبل افتتاح
غدا لاحظوا الطاقه الان ارتفاعاتها تقارب
العشره في المئه اما في السوق الكويتيه
فمعظم الاسهم القياديه تشهد انخفاضات من
الاسهم همم البنكيه مثل بيتك والوطني
انخفاضات الان تصل الى اثنين في المئه
وايضا الصناعات الوطنيه تراجعتها باثنين
ونصف النقطه المئويه همم برنت يبقى همم
فوق مستويات 83$ للبرميل بعد تراجعاته
بنحو خمسه دولارات يوم البارحه من اعلى
مستوى له في جلسه يوم امس عند 88 دولار
للبرميل هذه كانت وقفتنا مع الاسواق نعود
الان من جديد الى استديوهاتنا في الرياض
مع كيف فاطمه اشكرك ناصر
بدات سرعه الحمم البركانيه المتدفقه من
منى لواء الهادر في هاواي في التباطؤ وكان
البركان قد بدا في الثوران نهايه نوفمبر
الماضي منهيا اطول فتره هدوء في تاريخ
البركان المسجل من عام 1984
[موسيقى]
نهايه هذه النشره نختم بالعناوين
ناشطون ايرانيون ودول غربيه يشككون في
حقيقه تاثير قرار ايران الغاء شرطه
الاخلاق
في مطار ثالث
شركه طبيه تابعه لمالك تويتر
والبرتغال مع سويسرا
في امان الله
[موسيقى]